[Música]
cuatro astronautas para una nueva misión
lunar en 2024 la NASA dio a conocer este
lunes el nombre de la mujer y tres
hombres que conformarán la misión
artemis 2
Esta es su tripulación nuestra
tripulación la tripulación de la
humanidad
estos serán los encargados Cristina
hammock especialista de la misión y la
primera mujer designada para una misión
lunar
es una ingeniera que comenzó en godard y
no es ajena abatir récords registrando
el vuelo espacial continuo más largo
jamás realizado por una mujer
Víctor Grover será también el primer
afroamericano en una misión lunar será
el piloto de esta misión luego de haber
pilotado el segundo vuelo tripulado de
la nave Crew dragon en la misión spacex
es un aviador naval y piloto de pruebas
que ha volado 40 aviones diferentes
habrá un tripulante canadiense en la
artemis 2 será el precursor de este tipo
de viajes en su país Jeremy hansen
segundo especialista de la misión es un
maestro en ciencias de la física un
piloto de f-18 y un astronauta
canadiense Por último el jefe de este
reto lunar el comandante right jefe de
la oficina de astronautas de la NASA
hasta 2022
es un aviador naval condecorado y líder
del más alto carácter
la misión de todos ellos no será
alunizar en nuestro satélite natural
como hiciera la Apolo 11 la artemis 2
orbitará la luna por primera vez en más
de 50 años y buscará demostrar que la
NASA está preparada para volver a pisar
la superficie lunar La hazaña si todo va
según lo planeado tendrá lugar en 2025